this a moment to capture and cherish the
zagari rat cliffs hand in hand again
after six long years nazanin speaking
for the first time about holding her
daughter once more that moment was
precious i have been waiting for that
moment for such a long time and i was
overwhelmed um specifically to get to
know
gabriella
and richard after such a long time it
was a very very emotional moment
i haven't seen gabriella for the past
two and a half years be lovely to you
know to get to hold her to braid her
hair and to brush her hair that was the
moment that i really really missed the
most normal of life's moments so
precious and tinged with pain too
because i have seen five foreign
secretaries changed over the course of
six years that is unprecedented i mean
how many foreign secretaries does it
take for someone to come out five
it should have been one of them
eventually so
now here we are what's happened now
should have happened six years ago
philip hammond boris johnson jeremy hunt
dominic raab it was liz truss who
finally got nazanin out the government
repeatedly refused to acknowledge the
link between your imprisonment
and that debt which has now been paid
and while you must be absolutely
delighted
to be home
i guess my question is do you feel
really angry with the government too i
always felt like i am holding this
black hole in my heart
all these years
but i'm just going to leave that black
black hole in my heart i'm going to
leave that black hole on the plane when
the plane lands i'm not going to live
for the rest of my life with the grudge
over the past six years it has been
cruel what happened to me
but i think i will i i do not want to
um
kind of uh
this moment is so glorious for me
and the mp who campaigned for her
freedom now demanding answers as to why
it took so long
she said to me the minute the debt was
paid she was home they were just pushing
her out of the door and you heard in the
conference she talks about how she was
told from the second week of her
imprisonment that she would be home if
we paid the debt so my question is why
didn't we pay the debt earlier
nazanin home but never forgetting those
left behind prisoner murad tabaz's
daughter here too to highlight her
father's case
i think we were just so eager for any
sort of positive result because we were
promised a furlough and a lift on a
travel ban and we've seen neither come
to fruition and at this stage we we
don't have that much
else that we can do but to to keep
fighting for her
the fight for nazanin won but only after
a long fought public campaign gabriella
told me on the phone one day i was just
sitting around that mommy you do realize
that you are very famous and then it's
me and then it's daddy
okay i'm fine and then i said okay you
know it's not good to be famous because
you know you want to have a normal life
and you know just to have ever and she
was like oh you're not going to be
famous forever maximum
so
and then we're just going to have a
normal family
now time to be normal and to get to know
each other again away from the public
gays but questions about what happened
to nazanin won't go away beth rigby sky
news westminster